I was told that you guys almost didn't
make it to our taping in time what
happened LA traffic is yeah yeah well it
wasn't really the traffic it was more
the driver
oh no hello not this again yeah what do
you mean was the driver was a problem
well we had a woman driver and I mean
generally well generally they are not
great come on look all I'm saying is
chick drivers are easily distracted on
the road you know it's like it's like
you may as well just like let a puppy
drive a car all right I'm sorry Adam I
don't know if you're joking or not but
what you're saying is pretty offense
Conan I am not joking they shouldn't be
allowed to drive okay they should you
know what they shouldn't be allowed to
vote doing what the hell was that Adam
you're ruining this interview this is
gonna go viral man we're not gonna go
see the movie they're gonna boycott oh
[ __ ] you're right look we've got to
travel back in time to 1945 and convince
my great uncle in Texas not to have
these sexist views that he'd later pass
on to me but my god you couldn't alter
the space-time continuum that could have
disastrous consequences here in the
present we've got to risk it
to the time machine
oh yeah
welcome back to the Tex O'Brien show you
having a good time hangs am I having a
good time did takes us win World War two
old by itself and then take over the
whole planet back in 1945 it sure did
old alright my first guest turn the new
film rootin tootin Texas hot tub opening
this weekend please welcome Craig
Robinson Adam Scott and Courtney
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright boys let's sit him down let's
talk about this here movie de Texas
really take over the whole world
Goodwin Craig he surely did
nice we screwed up a whole Texas planet
but I mean at least the women must be
pretty well what's a woman he had it's
just us man whole planet full of man
procreate in the way God intended it
giant sex rodeos to the Hot Tub Time
Machine
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back a text in the toaster
before we bring out our first guest I
just want to thank the telepathic cowboy
toasters who rule this planet for
letting me live and let me host this
here talk-show he had and all hail the
toaster overlords
good one telepathic cowboy toaster
sidekick Hey
all right our first guests are the only
three other human beings left on the
planet they got a new film out called
all hail the toasters part 382 please
welcome non toaster number one now on
toaster number two now on toaster number
three
[Applause]
to the same
[Music]
[Applause]
we're back and I swear this time I will
actually interview the cast of Hot Tub
Time Machine 2 when we come back
you